22,265,736
total users on School as of today. And
to get that big, we had to know how to
retain users. And one of the biggest
places we learned this from is the
communities on the platform itself. And
so in this video, I'm going to break
down what we've learned so far that you
can use to retain your customers longer
in any recurring revenue business. And
this is a special shout out to the
School and Sam. I'm taking all the
learnings that he put in the School News
and I'm trying to make them public cuz I
think they're awesome. So number one is
think of churn like a leaky bucket. And
then diagnose what's actually happening.
So your MRR, meaning your monthly
recurring revenue, grows when new
members are greater than churn members.
So for example, if you sell five people
and you lose four, your MRR will grow.
If you sell five new members and five
churn, your growth will be flat. You
begin declining when you have fewer new
people than people who leave. And so
tactically, what you want to do is track
those two numbers on a monthly basis,
joins versus cancels, and then force
yourself to label the businesses
growing, flat, or declining based on
that. That's thing one.
Thing two. You want to use retention
benchmarks. And so this way you can know
if you're good. And so I'll just give
you the School platform averages. Now to
be clear, this isn't uh churn for like
an insurance premium or an alarm system.
But if you sell anything that is, I
would say, a tradi- you know, a consumer
service that's not like a home service,
but just like a weight loss service or
anything that you'd help somebody uh or
remote service or anything that's like
an online service, um these metrics will
probably be much more correlated to what
you're at. And so the platform average
across School is 80% monthly retention.
So said differently, it's 20% churn. So
80% stay, 20% leave. That's the platform
average. Now the best groups have less
than 10% churn, aka 90% retention month
over month. The not good groups have
less than 70% retention, aka 30% or
higher. And so tactically, if less than
seven out of 10 people want to stay on a
monthly basis, you probably need to work
on your retention more than anything
else. It'll be the highest ROI lever.
Now, to put this in context, if you take
your turn from 20% to 10%,
or said differently, you take your
retention from 80 to 90%, you didn't
just get a 10 or 12% boost, you got a
double in the LTV per customer. Meaning
customers stay twice as long when you
make that change. And so, one of the big
things that people get confused about
these small numbers is that the smaller
the number, the bigger the change by
percentages when you make these small
tweaks. And to be clear, this is all
monthly in comparison to others, not in
comparison to have like a sellable
business or anything like that.
Real quick, I'm going to show you the
exact 10-stage roadmap from zero to 100
million plus that less than 1% of
companies finish. I've now done multiple
times, and so I can say with a lot of
confidence that these are the stages as
head count increases that you need to
get through. And I broke each of these
down by eight different functions of the
business, what the constraint feels
like, like what are the symptoms of it
when you're going through it, and then
what steps we actually took to graduate.
And we've done this across software,
physical products, uh service
businesses, brick-and-mortar, all of
this, and it works. And it's my gift to
you, it's absolutely free. And so, the
link's in the description, but you just
go acquisition.com/roadmap,
just enter your info, and it'll spit it
right back to you all free. So, number
three is the biggest rule is that churn
drops dramatically with time. All right,
so this is like this is a very cool
inference that that uh Sam shared with
me that I thought was really, really
interesting. So, it it it's very easy to
think, "Okay, my average churn is, call
it 10% a month." But when you actually
look at cohorts of churn, meaning people
who are at their sixth month versus
people at the second month versus third
month, etc., the averages across
platform are also very different by
month. And so, for example, month one to
three are the highest churn. So, they're
20% plus during these months. Now, if
you keep someone 90 days, which seems to
be the first kind of big churn drop-off
point, it drops to around 10% or less.
And you're like, "Huh, that's kind of
interesting." Basically, it drops in
half if you get people to day 90.
Now, by month six, so another 90 days
after that, churn gets extremely low.
So, it goes from like 10% to 2%. All
right, so a 5x decrease or a 5x increase
in LTV, depending on how you want to see
it. And so, the implications of this are
huge because a lot of people will
obsess, myself included, about like,
"How do I get my my monthly churn down,
you know, over and over again?" An
easier way to think about decreasing
your churn is not, "How do I make this
number go down?" but, "How do I get
someone to stay past day 90? How do I
get these people to stay past month
six?" Because those become much more
tactical in terms of like, "This is what
I can do." Now, to be clear, if your
community or recurring revenue thing is
less than 90 days old, then your churn
is always going to be inflated cuz you
haven't even gotten those customers
who've made it past that point that
would, over time, decrease your monthly
churn.
If it's less than six months old, it's
the same thing, just a little bit less.
And so, to be clear, don't overhaul your
entire business because your month one
churn sucks. Uh that's normal for it to
be higher than the other months, unless
basically everyone's leaving, in which
case, yes, you should go fix that. All
right, so that's number three. And I
think that one's like really, really
big, and I want to like hit on that.
Like,
I would say, if you had to focus on
three tactics, have a very specific
strategy for getting people past the
first month cuz that's the biggest month
of churn. So, that's going to come from
activation, onboarding, expectation
setting, selling the right promises on
the front end, showing up every day,
making sure that you're providing
content in that in that environment.
Day 90 is probably going to have to
deliver some sort of outcome, some sort
of change in behavior for them. Month
six, it's usually them connecting with
other people within that community. All
right, and so, this is kind of as these
things develop. Now, number four, ask
people why they canceled, and then look
for the patterns. So, I would say,
earlier on in my career, I would just
like when someone says, "Oh, it costs
too much." I would just ignore them. I'd
be like, "Oh, they just don't understand
the value." But over time, I've learned
to appreciate that like I'll tell you a
a cool little thing. Sam has
the head of customer support sits right
next to him
in the whole office. And the reason for
that is cuz he wanted a very tight
feedback loop between the problems that
customers are experiencing, the reasons
they're canceling, and the things that
are getting built. And that's why School
is such a strong platform, it's so good.
And so tactically, message people who
are canceling say, "Hey, why are you
canceling?" And don't knee-jerk, you
know, on one response to be clear.
They'll be like, "Oh, this one person
canceled." Like, look for patterns,
collect enough feedback uh to see them.
And so tactically, you can create a
simple DM script, and then you can tag
the reason that people have in an Excel
sheet. So, it could be like price,
overwhelm, not using, it's missing a
feature, or it's not what I expected.
And you can look at that, and for every
20 cancels or so, review the top one or
two reasons, and then fix those. Really
tactical advice, please do this.
Number five, ask your best members why
they stay. So, we're asking the bad
people why they leave, we're asking the
good people why they stay, and then do
more of that. So, identify the longest
tenured people, aka the most engaged
members, and then ask them like, "What
made you stay?
What's the number one value that you get
here?" And so then tactically, whatever
shows up repeatedly becomes your kind of
retention engine. And so everything else
after that is really optional. And I
would I want to emphasize this point.
If you can only do one thing that gets
people to stay, why would you do five?
And this is a lesson that took me too
long to learn because often times, we
believe that in order to fix things, we
need to fix them through addition. When
often times, we need to fix them through
subtraction and amelioration, aka making
it better rather than adding more stuff.
Because if you were to simply fulfill
the promise that you originally made,
they'd probably stay. So, if you think
about, "How do I improve the quality of
a product?" You make a promise, and then
you remove all friction associated with
getting that thing. And so the
businesses, the products, and the
services that win are the ones that
simply make all the things that suck
about achieving the good thing go away.
School fundamentally helps people get
started online. And so all we've done is
try to optimize to make it as easy as
humanly possible, and that doesn't mean
adding more features. It means making
everything in the background just vanish
so it just works, which leads me to
number six.
Price objections. You don't want to
guess, you want to tier based on
evidence. So at School, so us eating our
own dog food, we had a bunch of people
canceling saying, "It's too expensive."
And so what we did is we created a lower
tier while still keeping the higher tier
available with some additional,
uh, you know, metrics and, you know,
additional admins, things that, you
know, unique URLs, you know, no no
sidebars of competitor groups kind of
advertising the same area. We kept that
for the high-level people, but the
people who are lower-level, who are just
kind of hobbyists, who are just getting
started, we created a 11 times cheaper
tier from $99 to $9. Right? And so
this was important for School because a
lot of hobby groups are people getting
started and maybe they're not
necessarily making a ton of money. They
got to figure out a few months, and the
difference between $100 a month and, you
know, uh, $9 a month is pretty huge. And
so that allowed the people who were like
still figuring it out to still be able
to use the tool and stay and then
ultimately be successful longer term.
Now, tactically,
if your ideal customers, this is a very
important point, if your ideal customer
say the price is the issue,
then you can add a lower tier or a
standard plan. If non-ideal people say
it's too expensive, just ignore it. That
means that the price is actually acting
as a good filter, right? Like if you if
you're like, "I want a community for a
million dollar plus business owners,"
and people who are not a million dollars
plus say this is expensive, then it's
like,
"Great. Bingo. It's working." All right?
Um, same thing with whoever your avatar
is, which leads to number seven,
overwhelm. So let's talk about this. The
number one reason people churn, outside
of price, is overwhelm. It is the churn
driver. And this is why doing less can
often retain more. And so, the core idea
behind this is like, I don't have the
time, I can't keep up, I can't utilize
it. And usually just means there's too
much stuff. So, I want to I want to
break down a real-world example of this
outside of school that applied the same
concept. So, Planet Fitness uh is a $10
a month, you know, gym subscription.
They have some upsells, whatever. And
they were able to enter the market in a
place that there's already tons of gyms,
there's already tons of health clubs,
etc. But what they realized when they
surveyed customers is that people joined
health clubs and they were paying $59 a
month or whatever, and they had
basketball courts and racquetball courts
and uh cardio and pool and all this
other stuff, right? And when they
surveyed people, the vast majority
people just used the cardio equipment
and a little bit of weights.
And so, they were like, wait, so these
have these massively built-out things,
but people are only using 10 or 15% of
the facility. And so, what they did,
they said, what if we just took out that
10 or 15% put it over here and then
charge way less for it? And by doing
that, they had a superior value
proposition. Now, here's where it gets
really interesting.
When you have five things that you pay
for, but you only use one, you feel like
you're only getting 20% of the value.
If for the same price,
you just offer that one thing, people
feel like they're getting 100% of the
value. So, someone is more likely to
churn in this scenario because you added
more stuff because now they feel like
they're using not enough of it. Wild.
So, us as business owners a lot of times
we're thinking, oh, I'm going to I'm
going to add this, you know, I'm going
to add all this extra stuff, but the
reality is all we did is we gave them
more reason to cancel because they never
used it.
And so, we had a community on School
where they found out about this, they
deleted content that they had, and they
took their churn from 30%
month-over-month to five. They had a six
x increase in LTV by simply having fewer
things.
All right? A simple version of this is,
and I'll I'll give you a tactical uh
I'll give you a couple tactics on this.
So, you can make a a little form and
just simply ask your customers, hey, if
I were to delete everything, what one
thing would you fight for? And on the
inverse, if I were to keep everything
and just remove only one feature, which
one thing would you not mind seeing go?"
And then if you chart those on a graph,
what you'll find out is what the number
one and number two most valuable things
are. And often times it's really
outsized. And most of the time, you just
need to do those things and basically
forget about everything else. Cuz one of
the big things we have to remember is
that
people who are using your services are
not full-time using your stuff. They
have lives. And so we want to think
about value per second, not seconds of
value. And in the digital world, that
might mean just one post, one call
recording, or just one single action
that you need to take that's valuable
for them. That's it. If someone just
gets that every week from you, they're
in.
Which leads to number eight. Design for
the extremes. Have a busy path, like the
person who's just kind of like a dabbler
dipping their toe in the water, and then
also have kind of like the power user
depth. And so a busy member should be
able to get value from a distance. They
should be able to keep up and not feel
like they're left behind. On the other
hand, a hardcore person should be able
to go deep all day. And so tactically,
make an explicit start here
weekly cadence flow for the busy people,
while leaving optional kind of like side
quests and depth for the kind of like
heavy users or heavy Yeah, the heavy
users. Nine, move the ladder closer to
the front. So front-load the thing that
people love. So we use snakes and
ladders as a concept. So you want to
remove the snakes, aka the friction, the
confusion, the overwhelm. And if there's
a long ladder, the thing that makes
people stick, put it in the onboarding.
So tactically, if the calls are the
stickiest thing, or this specific
service, or this specific
implementation, or onboarding, or
activation, the best call replay,
whatever it is, the pin post, put that
sticky sticky thing up front. And you
want to pin, this is now a
school-specific thing, but it still
works with any onboarding, is you want
to pin the fast win up front so new
members hit that value ideally within
the first 24 hours. And this works for
any recurring business, whether you're
teaching someone how to sell, teaching
them to work leads, teaching them how to
pickle pickle jars, whatever. Like, as
long as you have a way to get people a
win fast,
they will like you more. 10, show up
daily and care. So, this is something
that we saw across all communities is
that the owners who showed up in the
community on a daily basis had
significantly higher retention than the
people who didn't. Big surprise. Now,
we've basically never seen this fail.
And so, if a member feels like the owner
isn't active or doesn't care, they
leave. And so, a tactile minimum would
just be like, put an alarm, make it part
of your daily routine.
And so, on a small level, you can clear
notifications, DMs, you know, uh report
whatever content or, you know, deal with
content that people might have reported.
Now, this is talking about school, but
you can apply this to your own business,
which is like, what am I doing every day
to show up for my customers and can I
make that a repeated action that I do
that's high value and high leverage.
This also means like, read the
complaints every morning of customers
who are dealing with issues. Because if
you if you want to hide your head in the
sand,
uh you will be
well, I guess your head will be in the
sand and that will suck cuz then you got
it in your ears and your nose and it's
like, you know, how are you going to
live, right? So, it's that's a tough
life. And so,
so, you know, encourage the good
behavior that you that you have, the the
people who follow what you want. People
leave nice reviews, people leave nice
testimonials. You want to tell people
and say, "Good job." On the other hand,
delete bad stuff and delete bad people.
I cannot tell you how powerful deleting
cancer is is. Like, if they do it in
your body, you should do it in your
community or membership. Which leads me
to number
11, which is a weekly call and a
recording. And so, live voice / face
deepens relationships. And so,
recordings kind of just like let busy
people keep up. There's very often that
there's like weekly podcasts that have
tremendous retention. It's just like
it's just enough like I think about TV
shows. Like obviously Netflix created
the binge culture but the vast majority
shows are like once a week. It's enough
that people can keep up with it.
And too many of these kind of like extra
add-ons, people kind of revert to that
one thing and you want to make sure that
the one thing they're consuming is the
best one. So if you're unsure what kind
of communication cadence to stick with,
just default to like one big thing per
week uh and then like a best of post.
Very simple. So it could be like weekly
call and weekly post. That's all you
have to do. Very very simple within a
community structure. Let's go to number
12. So you want to add an annual plan
with a discount. So the reason this
works is that annual always has lower
churn than monthly and it's because you
only need to decide one time rather than
12. And so annual buyers churn less.
And even beyond the they can't cancel
effect, right? So like because they
can't cancel because they already paid
is one element of that, but the other
element is just that like typically
those people are also more committed.
They also got a lower rate. So there's a
lot of and they're also more qualified
because they've paid more up front. So
there's a lot of and and and. So having
that is valuable. Now a common practice
here is 16 16 or 17% which is usually
buy 10 get two. All right. So if you're
not doing this within whatever service
you sell, have an annual component that
you should implement like today, like
right now, first thing you do after
this. Announce it and expect a
meaningful chunk of people to take it.
And what that does is it stabilizes
retention. 13, you want to build
belonging via one-on-one relationships
and 10 true regulars. Now this isn't a
digital community, but from a business
that has any kind of
community that's involved, real and
person, etc.
Fostering one-on-one relationship which
is thinking like what are the unique
aspects of these people who are coming
in and can I pair them with other people
who are like them? Because if people
find I think there's um
Layla shared this out with me. This is
on the employee side but it totally
transfers which is if an employee has a
friend that they are friends with
outside of work, they stay five times
longer at their job. Think about wow
that is. Just one friend outside of work
or one person that they're like really
good friends with. And so, like hack of
hacks, like get them to make one real
friend. Now, that's easier said than
done, but the nice thing that you should
have hopefully everyone should have one
thing in common, which is that they're
all uh patrons of your business. So,
they at least have that interest someway
in common.
And so, uh the fastest way to do this is
also introduce some of the true regulars
to the new members. And I used to do
this at my gyms. Like, otherwise
everyone just feels brand new. They feel
like in-group out-group. Like, you don't
want to have people feel like they're
walking in on someone else's
conversation. So, if somebody's new to a
party, right? And you're holding a party
and someone walks in, what do you do?
Oh, this is John. John, meet Tina. Meet
you know, meet Jesse. Meet meet Trish.
Uh you know, John's really good at X, Y,
and Z. Trish's great. John, blah blah
blah. Right? And so, it's just like just
help them build rapport, which building
rapport just comes down to like what
things do they have overlap over? That's
all it is. All right. Um but within the
digital community, so going back to
going to school,
you can anchor engagement in community
with 10 regulars. That's it. You just
need 10 regulars. The the tactical piece
of this is that identify the top 10
people. These are your model citizens.
The best customers. Your best avatars.
DM them. Figure out their goals.
Spotlight them, meaning give them public
kudos. Invite them to contribute, not
just like watch them do it. And if you
can, again, publicly recognize in any
way possible, it further reinforces the
behavior. And you want to introduce the
new people to them. AKA matchmaking.
Sometimes tactics can be very
overwhelming. Uh but sometimes they're
exactly what you need. Uh if you have a
recurring revenue business, don't expect
to implement all of the stuff at once.
Just take one thing off the list and do
it. Add it in consistently. And then
once you get consistent with that one,
add another one off the list. And so,
conquering churn or you know
uh trying to have an alliteration for
attention.
Like mastering retention, but I need an
R.
Something retention. Uh remastering
retention.
Um just comes down to doing 100 small
things consistently over a very long
period of time. And so most people think
that growth looks like this,
when in fact, growth really just looks
like a flat retention curve, and then
what happens is it just keeps growing.
And so I hope this helps. Keep crushing
it.